- Today's video is
sponsored by Skillshare.
So warm thank you to the
whole Skillshare team
to supporting the work on
my channel Firm Learning.
So you want to know what
the up-or-out principle
in consulting is and how it really works.
So for sure, when I was a young
student, about 10 years ago
this was always a thing that
really gave me headaches.
When I was thinking about
maybe joining consulting
after graduation, what
does up-or-out really mean?
How does it work?
Does this mean that I might lose my job
if I do some mistakes on a project?
Will I just be kicked out of the firm
if I'm not good enough?
So for sure these were
questions which were in my head
and I didn't really have
any resources at the time
to really understand this.
I always felt like this is a topic
that isn't really talked about
and for sure at some recruiting events
when I talked to representatives
of any of these firms
I never really felt like
that I got a straight answer
that somebody was really spilling the tea
on what up-or-out really
means and how it works.
So in this video, I'm
going to do exactly that
I'm going to talk about this little secret
of the consulting world.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm
Learning, my name is Heinrich
I'm a former McKinsey Consultant
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So before we start
I just wanna be clear that I'm not talking
about the situation of any specific firm
but rather talking about
the general situation
of tier one consulting firms
and I trust similar things will be true
for tier two and tier three firm as well.
It is also important to understand
that within the same firm
how strict this up-or-out
principle is applied
might vary by geography
also because of course the labor laws
a different country by country
with of course the residing implications
that come from that.
So in this video I will
tackle the up-or-out principle
in three steps.
First, I'm going to talk about
what the up-or-out principal actually is.
What does this really mean?
Then second, I'm going to talk about
how it really works in practice
and the third I'm going to talk about
what happens if you are
on the out part, right?
So if the firm asks you
decides that you cannot work
for the firm anymore in the future.
So without further ado, let's start
what does up-or-out even mean?
What is this even supposed to mean?
And indeed another word that
some people use is grow or go
and what this really boils
down to is that in the end
throughout your career in consulting
and you get either designated
either you get promoted to the next level
every other year or so
or at some point, if
you're not getting promoted
you will be asked to leave the firm.
So pretty much your work
contract will be terminated
you can assume that this
principle is applied
in a rather strict way
for all the MBB firms
and other tier one firms.
and again to some extent
also to tier two and tier three firms.
So then why do consulting firms do this?
What is their rationale for doing that?
Where they want to keep the
pyramid in the organization
and they wanna make sure
that their credit system
where the very best get to the top
and the people who maybe do not perform
to these highest levels that they expect
will at some point,
leave the organization.
This is exactly what
the up-or-out principal
is supposed to do so for our time
either you're good enough
for the next designation,
you're considered ready to
be promoted to the next level
or this is not a case.
You are not considered good enough
and then you will need
to leave at some point.
But of course, there's also a
criticism for this principle
and maybe you're familiar
with the expression
of the Peter principle,
which pretty much means
that in many organizations
people get always promoted up to the level
of their personal incompetence.
So people might be very good,
highly effective in the jobs
that they used to do, but
then they always get promoted
up to a point that they failed
they cannot do this new role anymore
and then often this means
that you need to leave
the company as the employee.
So if you translate this to consulting
what this means is that maybe
you're a great project lead,
maybe you do an excellent
job at managing projects,
managing your clients, managing your team
but maybe you just do not want to advance
into the junior partner
position as a next step
maybe because you don't
want the lifestyle,
you don't enjoy the tasks that
you will likely need to do.
So you would be very happy just to stay
in your project, lead role forever
this is just what you're comfortable with
this is what you enjoy doing,
this is also where you're really good at
and choices like this
are usually not possible
in these large strategy consulting firms
where the up-or-out principle applies.
So over time you either need
to go up or you need to go out
this is really what this boils down to.
So let's now move to the second part
how does this really work?
How is this principle
really applied in practice?
But before we jump into it
I want to introduce you to
the sponsor of today's video
and this sponsor is Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore news
skills, deepen your passions
and get lost in creativity.
There are classes on
marketing, personal branding,
presentations skills and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting,
banking or corporate
and the best thing is that
I made a slide writing class
for Skillshare so you
can access and enjoy it
as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently took the class
productivity master class
principles and tools
to boost your productivity
from the fellow YouTuber, Ali Abdaal.
It's a great class that taught me
many new aspects of productivity
and are very much enjoyed
how we applied the Pareto Principle
or the 80-20 rule to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning
there are no ads,
they're always launching
new premium classes
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you
and the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special
offer for subscribers
of this channel from learning
and so the first 1000 subscribers of me
that click on this SKillshare
link in the video description
will get a free trial
of the Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity
check it out, link in
the video description
and indeed would, most of
these consulting firms have
is that they have very highly
standardized careers tricks.
So if you joined these firms,
you already know from day one
that in one year he will
be promoted to this level
then in another year on average
you be promoted to the next level
then in two years to this level and so on
that you have an average time span
until you pretty much know
that this is your career track
that you can follow to
get partner at some point
of course, for each of these steps
there is some level of flexibility
and often this is described as a window.
So you have often a certain time window
with then you can make the
designation to the next step.
What is then means is
that in this time window
usually there are three points in time
that you can make the designation.
So if you are considered a high performer,
if you're considered a rock star
then you might have the
chance of being promoted
early in this window.
So earlier than your peers
and indeed often this difference
is only a couple of months
but if you are really one
of these high-performance
who always consistently is
able to get promoted early.
This really can add up
and then in the long-term
you might be able
to make partner one or
two or three years earlier
then there's the standard
regular point in time
where most people say
80% of all the people
will get designated.
So this is kind of the
average career track
that you will be on
and then there's also this late promotion,
the late designation, and
this is for the people
where for whatever reason,
the we're not yet seem fit
to be designated in the
standard regular point in time.
Maybe they've got some subpar
performance evaluations,
maybe there were some
things in their development
where some partners expressed the opinion
they still need to develop a certain area,
a certain aspect of their skillset
in order to be ready to
take on that new role
to take on this new
responsibility that comes
with the promotion attached to it
and then indeed, a few are
designated in this late spot
then you're fine, then you're designated
and then your journey continues.
and then maybe you have
another year or two
until the next window opens
and this gives them plenty of opportunity
to recalibrate also your
performance ratings.
But then of course what can happen is that
then within this window
there are people that
then do not get designated
and while on the more junior levels
its the big majority of
people get designated
as only a minority who
doesn't make this cut in.
The more senior you get
up to the partner level,
of course at some point,
the larger of the share of the people
who does not make it will
need to leave the firm
at some point in time.
Of course, what we need to understand here
is that these things do
not come by surprise.
You would have received several instances
of performance reviews before,
you will not be surprised
that this is then the result
if it really gets that far
this really happens to you
in the very end
and in the moment we're
also going to talk about
what really happens if you
are asked to leave the firm
or this process really looks like.
So stick with me here for a moment
but again, it does not come as a surprise.
It is a very transparent process
and of course the consulting
firm that you work for
usually wants you to succeed.
They already invested
lots of time and money
just to hire you
and already invested lots
of time into your training.
So they want you to succeed,
so often the different processes starting
of somebody starting to fall behind
where you will get coaching,
where you will get additional support
and then this does enable lots of people
to indeed improve their performance
and the make the cut to not in the end
be in this position where it
just doesn't work out anymore.
But then of course
every year people are
affected by up-or-out
people need to leave
then the question is, how does this work?
What does this really mean?
And this is now the
third part of this video
so what happens if you need to go?
And the other question
that I get most often
if I discuss this topic with other people
is that they say wait but
they cannot just fire you
there are labor laws there, right?
And of course this is a sensitive topic
for the consulting firms.
Everybody has a big interest
of not letting this escalate
to some legal type of situation.
So what usually happens is
that the consulting firm
will approach you,
will just try to work
something out with you
so that you can leave on
good terms and all of this
is handled in an amicable way.
So what this usually means
is that you will get
several months of time
now to reorient yourself,
for this time you might
also get a paid leave
so that you still receive the salary,
but can again maybe do some
interviews with other firms,
with other companies I'm
aware of several instances
where the partners that worked
with these effected candidates
tapped into their very own network
trying to find some job opportunities
which would be a good fit with this person
and then trying to have them
to get into this new role
after the consulting time
and then often of course,
some time of several agreement
might be part of the dealers way
depending on the individual circumstances.
So where there are some instances
where some type of legal
escalation might happen in the end
these are only the rarest
cases from my experience
nobody wins by doing that
especially for the tier one firms
you can trust that the consulting firm
will do their very best to
find an amicable solution
to the situation that both sides,
both parties can live with
and of course the other
aspect of that is that
because you as the effected person
as the effected consultant
because you know, already far in advance
that you're currently on a slippery slope
that may be half a year,
a year down the line
your future in the firm is really unclear.
Most people understand
that this is the track that they are on.
They already by themselves
try to look around
looking for other opportunities.
So many people will already by
themselves have left the firm
before it even gets to this former point
where the HR professionals
or the responsible partner
from the firm approaches
you to formally let you know
that this is now the
process that you're on
and you will need to leave.
So, but this creates some clarity
and transparency into this topic
and that now you're able to understand
the up-or-out principle much better
how it works, how it doesn't work
what this really is all about.
So as always, if you
still have any questions
leave me a comment below
in the comment section
and I will do my very best
to answer all your questions
and of course every comment
also helps me with the YouTube algorithm
and if you have your very
own firsthand experiences
of the up-or-out principal,
maybe you're even affected by it
in a negative way, if you
want to share your story
I trust this would be highly valuable
for the other people
here in the Firm Learning
community as well.
So I highly encourage you to do that
that would be great for all of us here.
So now, as always, if you took
any value out of this video
at all, please destroy the light button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date
on all of my content
and if you want to see even more from me
I also have an Instagram, you
can follow me on my handle
at firmlearning and
also have a mailing list
there's a signup link to this mailing list
below in the video description.
In addition, I'd also
love to connect with you
and get in touch on LinkedIn,
you can find the link to my LinkedIn
in the video description as well.
So feel free to just hit
me up, reach out to me,
love to hearing from you guys
and of course, thank
you again to Skillshare
the sponsor of this video.
If you're interested to
try out Skillshare yourself
have a look at the Skillshare
link in the video description.
I trust that there are
some highly valuable
and insightful classes that you can take
and then I want to say
thank you to all the members
of Firm learning you really are the OGs,
you are the guys who are really supporting
the work here the channel
and if you wanna become a
member Firm Learning as well
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
there you will get all the information.
What becoming a member is all about
so if you watch until the
end, thank you so much
this is warmly appreciated.
My name is Heinrich and
here at Firm Learning
I'm releasing videos every
single week on Saturdays
so stay tuned for next week
and until then, bye-bye,
good regan to all of you, cheers guys.